this the moment of truth coronavirus
will not be contained the nation must
prepare a sambar p.m. with a sobering
message I'm gonna be clear we're gonna
be clear this is the worst public health
crisis for a generation
I must level with you level with the the
British public more families many more
families are going to lose loved ones
before their time nearly 600 confirmed
cases but the chief science advisor
today said up to 10,000 of us could have
the disease already we are now in a very
new and different phase this is now not
just an attempt to contain the disease
as far as possible but to delay its
spread and thereby minimize the
suffering if we delay the peak even by a
few weeks then our NHS will be in a
stronger state that means new advice the
Prime Minister telling those who feel
unwell to stay at home from tomorrow if
you have coronavirus symptoms however
mild either a new continuous cough or a
high temperature then you should stay at
home for at least seven days to protect
others and health slow the spread of the
disease
the government's own coronavirus action
plan says the delay phase could see
schools closed and big gatherings banned
all of that still on the shelf we are
considering the question of banning
major public events such as sporting
fixtures and the scientific advices
we've said over the last couple of weeks
is that this banning such events will
have little effect on the spread we are
not repeat not closing schools now the
scientific advice is that this could do
more harm than good
the US has stopped flights from Europe
Italy has closed down completely Island
today has closed its school but your
action plan basically means asking
people to stay at home if they feel ill
and avoid cruises
can you understand why people watching
this might think you're doing far too
little to protect their families or bet
first of all I mean we have to to look
at the epic acity of the the measures
that were bringing forward in this I
mean as I've said throughout we're
looking at the science and we think it's
very important to maintain public trust
and confidence in what we're doing
throughout this this challenging time
always to be guided by the best possible
scientific advice the prime-minister
leveling with each one of us this is a
national challenge that will affect our
way of life there is no escaping the
reality that these measures will cause
severe disruption across our country for
many months the best scientific advice
is that this will help us slow the
disease and save lives even if things
seem tough now just remember that we
will get through this this country will
get through this epidemic just as it has
got through many tougher experiences
before if we look out for each other and
commit wholeheartedly to a full national
effort a prime minister asking us to
trust him and the experts in the fight
against coronavirus a huge
responsibility for him to carry as we
all prepare for our lives to change
bethe Rigby Sky News Westminster